what is up there reject nation make sure
to leave a like because today we are
going to check out dragon ball evolution
yay oh god why did we agree to this but
before we do that we're gonna need you
boys and girls to become a lord right
now now you're probably thinking isn't a
lord some type of royalty i will not
when you check out today's video sponsor
established titles they come in a big
scottish alert has never been easier
established title packs come with at
least one square foot of dedicated land
and a nifty certificate with your unique
plot number so you can look upon the
exact location of your land they work
with multiple global reforestation
charities and plot a tree with every
order plus they make great last minute
gifts can officially change your name to
lord or lady and even put it on a credit
card or a plane ticket established
titles is running a bag sale right now
bagpipes
and if you use the code real rejects
you'll get an additional 10 off your
order so go to establishtitles.com
slash rio rejects my code and officially
change your name to lord or lady today
oh yeah forgot to mention if you really
want to fully go watch a log or you sync
up with the time go for dragon ball
evolution over at our patreon for super
sexy rejects including everything else
we have to offer now let's actually do
the reaction
wait he's like crying sweating and
bleeding full of water
he's so hydrated right now
[Music]
do remember goku being pure white
this is very yeah
ethnically accurate
first one to touch the ground loses
prepare to eat dirt that's the scrap
that's the grandpa that's right
that's his
that's his grandpa
[Laughter]
cool it's like watching upgrade
proto upgrade
[Music]
oh god
he hit his melon on some melons you're
special goku no i'm different
i know that and they know that too
they push me so far
that i want to explode
foreshadowing
teach me to get the girl
teach me how to talk to her without
stumbling all over everything i say
teach me how to be normal teach me how
to dougie
you must have faith in who you are is
this supposed to be like a biyagi thing
i think it's trying to attempt to be a
miyoki thing
happy birthday to shinchu
is yours
what is it
it's a dragon it's dragon ball so what
to do by itself nothing
but together the seven dragon balls will
grant the holder one perfect wish so
keep it safe
always yeah not a [ __ ] monkey pop
this is some uh mystical dragon ball
magical artifact sweet
oh my god you're gonna pay for this
fuller
make
me pay geeko
come on
show me what
come on average high school student goku
carrie let's go
i'm gonna be late for class
beauty awaits me the colors oh
fan service
dude if you squint long enough your hair
is going to go white it may not be
accurate to the anime but it's relatable
i see myself in that young man
piccolo
[Music]
pick a scroll
[Music]
oh that must be another dragon ball what
she said be quiet you little [ __ ]
[Music]
this is an astrological phenomenon why
does she need a gun you know
i don't know
superstitions have marked solar eclipses
as the sign of the apocalypse in india
for example the eclipse symbolizes
[Music]
what might our ancestors say about the
upcoming solar eclipse well my
grandfather would say beware of the
nameks they're an alien race that nearly
destroyed earth over
2 000 years ago let's hope it doesn't
happen again
[Music]
where was the comedy record scratch
sound duty tech
you are
you are a creepy man
and how long does that hair do take you
you are drinking damn it
did you do that
uh
yeah
use your key
whoa
you know about key just because my name
is chi chi doesn't make me complete
idiot chi-chi fam
service
i'm not saying that chichi's a stupid
name i'm just saying that it's not
normal
uh but normal is overrated
i'm not saying that you're stupid
overrated i'm just i'm gonna
stop now i'm a white guy named goku
i'll be there
ready to [ __ ] you up
ready to brawl
gel you don't see gel too often anymore
straight up gel
complete with
mighty gooey
[Laughter]
pretty good effect yeah
i want a making of one there
goku
happy birthday
oh
goku
oh
no he forgot his grandma's gonna
be dead
he's gonna be dead and it's all gonna be
your fault
i made a promise that i'm not gonna
fight oh
don't worry it won't be a fight
he just poured that water out on him oh
man some splash on his shoes
these guys the martial arts uh
sure
look at that stunt double
these what motion gags
doing good
[Laughter]
is that what is her name
is she in
say the girl black lightning or the one
in the dex new dexter season either way
she's hot as hell yes
[Laughter]
maybe that's why i cannot conjure her
name
what happened to your parents uh i don't
know but my grandpa said everything will
be explained to me when i turn 18.
and i'm 18.
and i forgot about my birthday with him
[Laughter]
you said it parrot
no
grandpa you just let the candles burn
all the way down on that cake
wow
why even
just enter piccolo
that was a cool shot
not bad yeah a lot of people like this
movie
this is an underrated gem i think
something's wrong what i have to go i'm
sorry
goku i'll see you later
that's not different at all every guy
runs off
grandpa's my cake around
i'm hungry
my long run
i didn't need anything at the party
it has begun
it has begun
remember always happiness
and who you are
what do you say
he said always have faith and who you
are who you are
and from that day forth goku had given
up high school parties
i will never party
[Laughter]
again all six dragon balls are right
here
definitely don't wait to see your face
where is it
i know it's here
[Laughter]
did you kill my grandfather listen idiot
and if i did kill your grandfather i
would have shocked you by now wait a
minute somebody stole my promethium orb
and i'm here to get it back
what aren't they on shameless together
i'm not letting anyone take it from me
four stars
prometheum or past five stars
who's the idiot
look at it
i bet you feel real stupid now
somebody hacked the vault killed the
guards and stole the dragon ball
capsule corporation which is also the
umbrella corporation
[Laughter]
how'd you know i had the dragon ball a
little machine i invented
this can detect and locate the signature
wavelengths emitted by the dragon balls
oh man what an asset you made a dragon
ball energy locator
cool dragon ball energy dbe
catchy name
dpe that's this movie's initials this
whole thing feels like a 2000s trailer
oh absolutely hey where's your uh
right
cool not a bad effect
start a counter of every time something
isn't that bad
we're not breaking in
door's unlocked
all right this girl's out of control
it's still
you know entering without permission
nah man that'll hold up in a court of
law
it's not breaking in door was unlocked
that means anyone at any time like an
invitation
you know i don't really remember the
show
so it's nice to have something
accurately depicted all this that's
right man bring all the memories this is
a good digest to get me caught back up
just in time to dedicate my life to
super broly
yes it is chariot fat thief
[Music]
[Music]
oh so much cracking
[Laughter]
do you have a dragon ball
bikini quarterly
oh
that's a collector's edition
good cover he's a pervert
[Music]
anybody think to check where the ominous
glow is coming from
the stock footage from germany or too
[Laughter]
each one has different stock footage
inside i kept my part of the bargain now
it's time for you to keep yours let's go
if what goes that is true
and piccolo is here
this wish may be the only thing that can
save our world we'll go
but we go together some great adr in
that scene oh show you and fed what
why did you do that yes
oh my god he hates the environment
shuttle crane strength is the most basic
of all the air bending things to
remember what i have to teach you you
have to become stronger
you wanted him although i am beginning
to appreciate the entertainment value
all right
huh
if only we were in your position bulma
am i
[Music]
something tells me the director
didn't even read the manga
[Applause]
i heard about your grandfather's
accident i'm so sorry
the house collapsed
what oh right hey what was it that you
wanted to tell me she just nobody at
home knows this but
i'm a fighter too
they just wouldn't understand must be
any mistake
common mishap in uh
movies
you just lost the scene where goku shows
any emotion over his dead grandfather
[Laughter]
i'm getting a strong signal from a
dragon ball only three miles ahead
oh my goodness what is going on why was
this whole movie shot on a green screen
whoa
needed held down there
nope let me handle this vegeta
[Laughter]
if you could just help me and my friends
out for a pretty thing like you
no problemo yamcha at your service uh
yeah i'm gonna need some payment
it's okay vegeta will show up soon
you're nothing but a low-life bandit
yeah
but what with the ladder
cause after the sun comes out it's gonna
be hot hot hot
hot they were told to deliver their
lines like an anime
but shot it with no style
there's one thing this director knows
about anime it's how the characters look
voice over word
we're gonna do the whole movie in
voiceovers
enough games we have no time to waste
how would you like to make more money
than your air force
now you're talking bro
[Laughter]
[Music]
we wouldn't be able to get this dragon
ball
well everything happens for a reason bro
got that one from daytime tv
the set dressing on this movie is so
good
so after we get to seven dragon balls
how soon can i expect some profit just
casually walking through this mountain
of love
yeah man it's what it's like in wherever
this movie is set the problem is how to
get across
yeah that's the problem with this movie
it's one big metaphor
orcs
good thing they're right by some lava
hey
we should all be so
lucky you got this goku
the floor is lava
oh man it's her one
the power to prevent this
is inside you
oh [ __ ] letter right to it
the adventure never stops
and problems get solved at such a
difficult rate
the only chance the world has now is in
toy side
toy son
it's gonna be good this movie is so
boring
this movie is
oh oh my masterwork
what do you say it's this is a
masterwork man
don't insult my favorite boy
what are you talking about i don't i
don't
you're
crazy it's the only way
i'm the only one who can do it
we will have it ready by the morning
namaste
these scenes are so bad
they don't feel like they're out of some
kind of daytime soap opera no real
urgency
there's no momentum
well there's an amazing favorite part
oh yeah wait are they just fighting each
other to start everyday
maybe it's a flashback
why to determine
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh no she had an ulterior motive
goku every time you eat there's a room
just like nothing else matters nothing's
happened before or after this
i wanted to be rich
well neither of us are gonna get what we
wanted oh i don't know about that i'm
not so bad once you get to know me
maybe i like bad men
[Music]
bow chicka bow wow oh snap
i would say for this movie to be
more fleshed out and breathe better it
would need to be longer but i also want
it to be over
why would you even speak those words in
a sentence together like that
just putting the idea out there might
happen
but he said that i wasn't ready to learn
it yet
you are not
this guy is awful
he's not good he's not good i think he's
been good in other stuff but it's not
this
i don't know how he got this role
i'm pretty sure this guy smoked weed
from every dinner
he knew well enough what was going on
even then
he's really good at playing slightly
frustrated
[Laughter]
yeah man that's the cool man's anger you
know my grandpa always said
in order to master my key
i have to be at one with myself and with
my enemy well that's why you still call
me that one with everything
there are five unlit torches in this
courtyard every time you light a torch
you get to take one step closer to me
what happens if you're like all five
torches then you'll be standing right
next to me where i can reach you set the
place on fire
ah
[Music]
man she is so hot for him it is
ridiculous i know she loves this guy
take one step back
that wasn't the rules my game
my rules
now you'll never stand next to her it
doesn't feel right i must be missing
something you have to make every move
your own you can do this
i'm your mentor now
the rave moves
you did it goku wowie that's like four
steps i think the next move it would be
better to blow out all the torches
nice
yeah
buddy
oh you you even did it
too overachiever why couldn't she open
her locker
that's a good question isn't that a
curfew in this temple
night
oh hey you guys are up late
were you in your room
she's got the dragon balls no chichi
chi-chi how could you chase
steal dragon balls which can't open a
locker wow
no
no
who the hell are you
oh man this movie has everything
we'll find another way
some were piccolos floating in the sky
i'm pretty sure goku can get past that
chi-chi's
wrong one
oh no
goku
oh
what
no way
[Laughter]
she put up one heck of a
fight hey it's like how we saw the
dragon balls i'm so happy to see you i
have an emotion for you grandpa it's not
your time goku
there's much left to do
oh he's good at playing slightly how do
i defeat ozark
it's really hard grandpa
yep it's pretty much a one stop shop for
all your needs
all purpose spell could be
man
hey chow yeah i did in hawaii
make like thousand dollars
you led some credibility to our film
contained piccolo
good luck my friends dude he just he
gave him a proton pack this is so dumb
self-contained piccolo
go malekith
i hope you're not trying to impress me i
wouldn't mind but i'll still for scaring
the crap out of you
[Music]
i have to stop it before he finishes the
prayer what no after
hey man one of them could be hurt
here we go
first good fight scene coming up it's
gonna happen
he's got his outfit oh
yes hooray
we made it
fans served i will defeat ozaru and i'm
here to destroy you
defeat ozaru
everything sounds like it was
a conditional
[Laughter]
[Music]
them
oh nokum
[Music]
only with faith
can you win
accept jesus christ the faith in
yourselves
come on go super saiyan first rule is
there are no rules
hell yeah
this is intense
who else does that watch the baby i
didn't care how fast-paced the plot was
this is where we get to those credits
last year
can we speed this up
just consolidate the final action i know
what has to happen
some great slide moments in this movie
people be sliding everywhere
erotic gutter
that was a close one i
am azaru
to be a one with myself i must be too
oh man a whole lot happened for 10
minutes for this guy
yep
come on
i must
have faith
in who i am
yes
hey you know i was pretty cool it was
not that's cool not all together uncool
this is really the story of how his hair
got big that's right
the volume goku
one wish
will be granted
one wish to rule them all bigger dick
a thousand wishes
i compel you to come forth and grant my
wish
[Music]
[Music]
everyone's hair makeup is on point i had
the stranger's dream
i was in the place i i can't describe
i felt content
like i belonged i was happy oh
daniel grandfather go ahead came up to
me and kicked me out sad there was a lot
you still needed to learn he's right i'm
sorry master roshi we just weren't ready
to have you leave us emotionally just
unprepared i know
that's sweet ladies but notice we're
missing something here the dragon balls
are gone we have to find them again
hey chichi sorry for kicking you in the
face
i feel terrible about it can you tell
how terrible i feel am i acting
really been thinking long and hard about
how terrible i feel
i don't care that you kicked me in the
face i'm just happy to see you
god she is all about him
now the real cheat she should walk in
what are you doing sorry that i heard
you i would never do that on purpose it
was just i was in the heat of battle and
i thought you were someone else sorry i
let you hit me
i was just too fast you're fast but i
let you hit me oh you kinka
[Laughter]
you got some fun at it if our
relationship is gonna go anywhere
we're gonna have to settle this
[Laughter]
fifty shades of goku
come on
[Music]
cool
oh james wong you did this james wong
director of
of the hit jet li action time travel
multiverse movie the one
the one is much better than that stephen
chao produced the is this the same
stephen chow it's like i think steven
chow was originally supposed to direct
this actually or at least to ask him to
i could see some of the wannabe style of
it but now the
the one at least had good action
that was that cool effect that was that
one effect that was kind of neat
oh my gosh
sketchy
this is the only scene in this whole
movie that's moved like this
christ's sake
oh
what
piccolo will return
all right before we begin
let this movie uh okay
um
what did it do right
it
uh
here's one
here's one
it's set up uh what the dragon balls are
supposed to do
that was clear
yeah one thing movie did right
that was fine
uh-huh
i'm so surprised at how this turned out
partly because what year what year was
this movie
either way i feel like this was made far
past an era
this feels like it was
made 20 years before it was actually
made this feels like a late 90s early
2000s like bargain bin
movie that somehow managed to be grafted
on to like the
biggest anime property at the time
i guess that's why i'm surprised at how
this turned out
because
there was
that this lacked
so much
um
i'm really trying to like
because this is the kind of movie that
has been i know has been clowned on
forever
and and and i don't want to just like be
another
thing too you don't want to just throw
be like oh are you yeah i'm ranting
about trying well evolution yeah yeah
watch me rant it's not worth it um
let's see my method
with doing reactions is very simple
just uh
reflect how a movie's making me feel
over a show or a trailer
it's simple right it's all it takes for
people and um i just feel like so empty
so you you took on
goku's you know demeanor over the course
of dude he is so bad he's so zen he is
goddamn i don't i don't enjoy bashing on
actors performances but
halfway through i was like
wow this this guy is like not good in
this movie he's not even trying to be
good
except for maybe towards the end i don't
know what his because
his approach was so inconsistent it was
either
like okay maybe you were misguided and
you went for subtle oh
but then other times i'm like why are
you doing this like anime delivery voice
uh in certain scenes so it just
did not mesh uh whatever he was doing
and bottom line like it
there's one thing with being subtle and
like playing it into like the
body language and the eyes
and then there are other times i'm just
like nah you just look dead behind the
eyes man like there's like nothing there
it was just like you're not ryan gosling
yeah
you can't just pull your eyelids down a
little bit and have that be the thousand
miles to you actually got to be like
thinking about character life yeah
yeah everything felt like it was an
audition
everyone felt like they were auditioning
yeah like everyone felt that way i like
jamie chung
she i mean he seemed the most engaged in
the scenes with her
i mean she was good she's good she's a
great actress yeah she's a great actress
yeah and she just cr she crackles with
energy for sure and uh she brought the
most life in here
absolutely um i do think it's really
funny how whenever
aren't they like in the in the show
like they were like childhood friends
right and and and she was always smitten
with him is am i getting that correct am
i thinking of someone else
my memory is so like
yeah
but either way like every time he shows
up she's just like
drop everything
yeah
you're my life
i'm all about you going i have committed
to you forever even though we've seen
the entirety of your relationship so far
on screen yeah it seems somehow like you
are just fixated on this guy who you
just like finally started to talk to a
day ago
um everything falls
either flat or
a bit annoying
i was never like so annoyed that i
wanted to turn it off
i was just
annoyed enough
it just felt like
what's the word i'm looking for
oh it's not exactly a harsh word
tedious tedious yes
tedious is good
good word to describe this yeah i'll
meet you there it did it was like moving
so fast but i could not care about
anything
that i'm like which so whatever gets
this movie over fast yeah so i'm gonna
wrap it up
yeah
like the way plot points work in this
are just so
rushed
and it doesn't even bother me because
it's so
boring like it's boring and i think
that's the biggest insult you could do
for any movie is make it boring
yeah then i can't especially can't
handle boring especially a movie with
this broad of a lore
and as colorful of a source material
and
as uh i don't want to say high
production value as this was but clearly
they wanted to throw a lot of effects at
this and so for such an effects heavy
well the thing i have to well what i
mean by that is that like there's so
many inexplicable green screens like
there's there are cg creatures and stuff
but their sets are awful though the sets
are awful
the green screen war the thing is for so
much of the movie because of the awful
sets and then the green screens that
look and come across very obvious and
are clearly doing certain things where
you have these motion issues that clash
with the subjects on screen and all
those things work together to make it
feel like you're watching some kind of
lost episode of power rangers but like
way
less engaging than power rangers even
because and i don't know if it's you
know maybe it's just the quality of the
stream we had or something but there
yeah there are these moments where even
just like the the quality of the the
film just looked like it was
it literally started to feel like a low
budget like a power ranger show yeah
yeah no it looked like that mortal
kombat annihilation um it was awful
the
the villain piccolo
oh my goodness great see i'm i'm not
even here to like talk about
accuracies
right none of that is upsetting to me
because i don't remember it well enough
to be you know
offended
yeah
piccolo is what was this is one of the
worst villains i've ever seen this is
like a terrible terrible villain oh yeah
he's just he spends the entire movie and
his big sky ship
in his bondage costume just
just being grumpy and serious
well he's got the
okay
i'm used to the cliche of of male
bad guy has like this
[ __ ] awesome fan fatale lady who does
the violence but that's the thing though
is they they usually send the one that
cat that character to be the hit man
while the other guy's like genius super
villain
and and this guy is nothing guys i think
he's [ __ ]
since he's nothing he's just like a dude
who
has a few lines a dude with a cool car
who wants power and he crushes the house
sure but then it makes me go what's the
point of your evil henchmen if you can
do that yeah what do you mean
it seems like you will get everything
done much more efficiently if you would
just go devastate everyone until you got
your dreams and you would be a villain
then you would actually be a real
villain by that point if if you were the
one going in there killing people all
the time and
like you were just like a man on a
mission you know that would have been
cool it was like out for revenge but
there's this movie for a movie that
supposedly is seven days before the
world ends has no pulse there's no pulse
to this film they're like an awful
version of some dark sided steppenwolf
just like because that's all he gets to
do is just sort of stand around while
his hench lady does all the work and
then the ending fight isn't even
you know something to behold really like
they didn't give them anything to work
with at all and i mean i like james
marsters
but underneath
the makeup and the generic costume they
put him in yeah it's just like
there's nothing it doesn't go like
there's no direction to anything well
the dynamic is insanely flat
between
him and woman person
so flat
the way the ensemble forms feels just
bizarre
it's just perfunctory it's just the plot
is the plot is the main character and as
it moves an ensemble happens
yeah
i i lost track of like wait where are we
i don't care
that's a bad sign yeah or you're cause i
feel like even a so bad it's good movies
sometimes will compel you to keep track
uh
even if it's you know a wild delivery of
of ideas or whatever but yeah the three
fighters is so bad it's good street
fighter that is like
so bad it's good i really enjoy the hell
out of street fighter
it's charming
it's there you go this is not very
charming no there's no fun it's not it's
like a personality oh man that was
really that was rough this feels like if
you watched it feels like you watched a
so bad as good movie but where most of
the really endearing parts got edited
out for tv and then this is like the tnt
cut you're left over with yeah you know
and yeah it's like even chaoy on fat
like
i enjoyed watching him but i'm like oh
how did they what dirt did they have on
you why is ernie hudson here why are you
guys doing this like
i get why justin chatwin and emmy rossum
who i believe both are on shameless
together like i believe like yeah they
weren't there yet so sure they're in
this movie
but yeah like china and fat like
especially because this is borrowing
from
you know it's borrowing from japanese
anime but ciao fat obviously has tons of
experience with combat martial arts on
the screen so i'm like sure
if this was any if this was approaching
in any way like this feels like one of
those adaptations that doesn't even seem
like it really cared to approach
trying to honor the level of what it was
supposed to be so yeah i'm like why
this must have looked really good on
paper or something
because
yeah like i don't know and i don't feel
like he would need to slum it like this
but you know here here we are i guess
and it's weird because yeah it's like
everything too it's the one thing that
feels the most like an anime is the fact
that pretty much everything is adr'd and
yeah all the delivery is stilted and
animationy yeah you know to a different
degree
but that just makes the performances
look bad on most of these characters
when it's when every when the world is
at stake and yet there feels like
there's no stakes at all you got a real
problem on your hands yeah it feels like
nothing matters and it doesn't even feel
like there's momentum for the main
players
the whole movie is is the same demeanor
as goku pretty much it's like piccolo in
the post-credits scene
like they really built it up like he's
still alive like oh i was i've never
like felt threatened by this guy yeah
you didn't even get a real chance of
winning ever no
impression gary yeah yeah he's nothing
he does the requisite you know you
killed my grandfather oh no but yeah
otherwise he's just standing around
being grumpy on his ship and then at the
end you know he wakes up and he's
supposed to feel his port tent but it's
it's the same stilt he just kind of
looks
and i can tell you're just holding for
the shot
yeah know
it's one of those where yeah you feel
the artifice almost the entire time
it's so flat
yeah and on the again movies like this
at the end of the day it's like just get
get some cool action
that's lit like as much as i don't want
to be that kind of viewer i'm like yeah
that's all you need for this is that
could save this entire movie yeah it's
like if you have one good quality
that can make the other things weirdly
feel charming yeah
like you literally you keep this movie
exactly the same
but if the action was good
because it was like competent well done
imaginative
and then you go back to the shitty
scenes yeah somehow those shitty scenes
will feel at least like
kind of charming because it'll take on
the charm of an old martial arts movie
where the martial arts probably was
actually good and the scenes were you
know stilty or whatever you know like
it'll yeah feel like a lost
you know bargain bin martial arts gem or
something i guess
yeah it just feels like a a weird
like music video mess from the 2000s i
don't know what they were going for with
this film yeah
nothing's established i had no idea what
they were going for
this was like the
the weirdest
like terrible crowdfunder so
movie and i'm like i can't tell where
this is taking place and i mean i know
it's a different time but it's it's also
we just like weird to have a completely
unaddressed like
yeah goku white yeah why is why is goku
around the end when they're like you
know you got to be both goku and uh
whatever the other you know werewolf
entity's name is and i'm like both these
japanese names on this white character
who i thought again different time less
stress in clarifying these things but a
time in which i feel like it would still
stand out that this is just a white dude
and i feel like they could have even
thrown in one line of dialogue saying
that like
he's mixed ethnicity or his grandfather
is not his real or something
why did they name him goku
it draws
it's not like it's just different time
it's
he's
comes from a lineage of asian people
yeah
so you have to address it in some way
like you're calling attention to itself
unless he's playing
like an asian guy yeah didn't you see
how that informed his performance he's
clearly doing an impersonation of asian
people
i i don't know
that was um
that was really
that was really bad that's like that's
like bummed me out kind of bad
not even
a movie has to be so bad that you walk
in expecting it to be so bad
and then somehow you still walk away
pumped out
right now yeah it's such a weird feeling
and it very felt like i had a hope since
the day like maybe it's not as bad like
no i had a feeling it'd be bad but like
oh no i just
i'm not even like enraged i'm just
just bummed you know yeah you wanted to
have some fun with this like this kid
how they can does this have a cult
following for being like amusing
because i don't even see how they could
reach that standard
uh like yeah i mean i could maybe fathom
how it could but it doesn't seem to have
enough uniquely terrible i feel like i
like in this aftermath here sitting here
just thinking about it i feel like
i was just told a story by a kid
no i feel like it was
purdue crowdfunded by
some filmmaker's dad
my son has this idea for the show he
really likes and we're going to make it
our
dragon ball property yeah but my son
wants to direct so let him direct that
let him direct a lot of ideas i know
that's not the case yeah it's james wong
with the g can you know i want i want
people no in case you're only listening
it's wong
not juan wong and um
it's funny because the both asian
directors was a much more superior yeah
yeah yeah
hey
hey
that's scary
shitty words about the one all right
uh the one is good
that's not good that's entertaining but
that that's the goddess
there are enough character scenes with
good actors that kind of were enough
that the cool ass crazy action yeah it
holds it all together
let the bodies hit the floor
soundtrack yeah oh wow they're all
floating and stuff it's stupid but cool
yeah yeah yeah absolutely for sure and
this does not approach any of that
enjoyability
whatsoever and it has a one fight with
the two jamie chung's that's kind of
neat i guess i did it better than the
one
there were even more people to deal with
like it would be harder to do and i
think the one
that was what 2001 like i feel like that
was before this movie it was like right
after matrix that movie yeah yeah yeah
it's weird it's like because yeah i
don't have a great frame of reference
for all of dragon ball z
and so i'm not sitting here thinking to
myself like man i think what an insult
to jordan it's all just a bad move yeah
yeah yeah like you hear like a bad movie
you know like yeah i'm the kind of
viewer where it's like yeah there are
characters i know the names of who
didn't show there's no krillin there's
no you know
vegeta or frieza or any of those things
but it's one of those where i do feel
like
as much as they have the kamehameha
they do like the bare minimum of the
requisite stuff it does feel like they
didn't even really go out of their way
like the collecting the dragon balls
even though that is the plot like feels
so kind of backseat and and
i feel like you could have had a couple
actual like freaking power blasty this
feels kind of like the mortal kombat
yeah he wrote the hero final destination
that was that's a good one oh hey see
there you go i like his work on i see
his name a lot of american horror story
i like his work on american horror story
quite a bit mm-hmm it's weird yeah it's
like this is pretty small for what i
like
seems like he's a better collaborator
perhaps
than like a full-on uh offshore maybe
not
that's like going you're like there's
gotta be like a lot of great thing i'm
like oh no
i mean this this dude also has a a a
direct final destination too yeah and uh
but three yeah didn't he do megan is
missing because that's that's a movie i
think he wrote and directed which is
like no
don't see it on her
megan is missing i i'm pretty sure it
was the same guy who who works on
american horror story and and
i believe he's an asian man so it's not
is it called megan is missing i'm pretty
sure it's megan is missing
because that is either way that is like
a you know famously really bad movie
with like a lot of intent behind it
um so you know like
i guess this is michael [ __ ]
okay never mind racist i am a racist
racist racist
hey do you want to play goku
i have been training my entire life to
be able to play goku um
also worked on americans
yeah all right so not as bad as that
then but but yeah i mean this this
doesn't speak to the level of work i've
seen james long be able to handle but
but yeah it's like it it doesn't even
have enough of like the surface it
doesn't utilize the surface level dragon
ball z stuff enough to no there's no
panache yeah there's no obsessed yeah
it's like flat it's flat
and there are moments where part of me
was like i
i
i can't tell if it's even intentional
but there are times where it feels like
the movie is trying to behave like anime
and you know there's a delivery
definitely the delivery and there are a
couple of moments like in the way that
it attempted to handle humor especially
like when they're meeting chow young fat
and things like that i was like
for moments when you squint you're like
okay this does feel like it has this oh
and in the classroom that was what made
me think of it where the background
melts the way and she's in the field and
you know he's like fantasizing about her
and i'm like okay this seems like
one
small instance in this movie that feels
like a direct choice
that's trying to get somewhere maybe a
little interesting because even you know
back when this was made it was less even
prominent than it is now to recreate
that style live action yeah the high
school stuff was more
entertaining yeah and then it feels like
once it got to the actual attempting to
be dragon ball z stuff it got less
anime-like as it went well i it does
even anime-like is such a broad term
it doesn't feel like it's trying to be
the anime style that dragon ball was
yeah if anything they're just kind of
going for like generic
anime genera yeah just animating and
choices that might make you think of an
anime you know yeah um and it's it's
kind of like mortal kombat in that way
too where where like all of the new
mortal kombat movie has better fights
and at least
is better constructed overall but
there's entertaining gore yeah there
there is entertainment value to be had
there's at least one fun character to
watch maybe even a couple um but that
movie has that thing where you feel like
by the end like you kind of didn't see
mortal kombat like you did but it's all
building up to you know maybe next time
we'll do the tournament yeah and this
this kind of felt like that too where
it's like yeah you get the dragon balls
together and he makes a wish and all
that but it really feels like you know
the real heft of of what these battles
are and the conflicts of this world
we'll do that next time super saiyans
and all that [ __ ] we'll get into that
later like he didn't even get blonde
hair well yeah this had one expectation
i wasn't even sure what the journey was
that goku was going on
like what he had to grow into
why he had the suit and had to learn the
kamehameha
i i think he i mean
usually it's like a character has to
have some type of physical journey
that but really it's about who they will
change into by the end of the movie
i'm like
this is this guy's like seem to have
like a real lack of faith in himself
because they keep saying like
believe in yourself goku and i'm like i
don't really get much inner conflict
from you
i'm a guy
you seem like you're pretty confident
like you know anytime you have a
pickle
anytime you have a pickle to get out of
you you seem like you you get out of
there pretty fast like you handle the
situations really fast you're neither
over nor under confident and like at the
high school party when you let all those
dudes beat themselves up and you're like
head sliding across the car it seems
like you believe enough when the time
calls for it like they're looking for
the dragon ball i don't know it's just
it was terrible like i could give two
shits about the main character and it
was just so
the whole thing felt like just
like it was dragging its feet
okay let me have this
this is dragging its feet through the
whole thing so yeah i don't know um well
he's training through the whole movie
i guess that's his ark his eventually
whatever you train into
the guy who can do the copy on me that's
what it's interesting
him being upside down in the truck bed
and him moving the orange and all that
other [ __ ] it's just you're not good
enough goku it wasn't even like really
building up to that like i wasn't even
sure why we just kept cutting back to
some of this
mundane tasks
for goku's
personal life i'm just like just find
the dragon balls get this over with i
mean yeah
there's so many places where this could
have gone wrong and part of me doesn't i
don't want to
put a blame on any particular place
because this whole movie could have been
better but i was also like man
it doesn't seem as though this guy did
much home i feel like you could bridge
some of these gaps with a little
homework yeah little pathos you know
with a little
maybe he's like i didn't want to
influence too much of my style you know
i'm like what style what do you mean
this is like some
terrible tv power ranger [ __ ] yeah it's
not good
not charming like power rangers either
no no fun
look guys we're ending this we're done
with this movie anymore
uh yeah it's the first movie reaction
where i
had only like
a tiny positive thing to say and frankly
half of why i think she's good is
because i also find her just incredibly
attractive you know
that's one factors in for my viewing
experience which she's also like
no i would say even more than that she's
actually like the one of the only actors
in this movie that
seems to strike a charming tone and yeah
she's the only one who does where
everyone else is just so boring or weird
and even giant fat's kind of annoying
yeah yeah and and yeah she actually kind
of coalesces she doesn't look like she's
in a costume like obviously costume and
wig the writing is [ __ ] but she she
brings a lot of like natural sincere
charm
she seemed to have the right
the right
something or another pitch for this
yeah
yeah she wasn't like trying to be heavy
and she wasn't when she wasn't on nor
was she mocking the material yeah yeah
it was just right
she did good way to go jamie chung this
is your standout performance
mvp of the movie
in dexter too
right and then make sure i'm not racist
yeah
get you each get one [ __ ] oh no it's not
her god i don't know i i i do think it
is her but i can't remember if jamie
chung is the one who played um
uh oh maybe notice her oh thank christ
yes i remember her in gotham she was
great absolutely beautiful
still still looking at that
it's okay i'm sure one of the choices
made during this movie was hey jamie
chung very appealing very attractive and
hey that choice
is evident
in the movie so hey that's another thing
around all right
she's been around like i've seen there's
so many things
um
and uh who's the one in [ __ ] she's in
circle punch it's one of the moves you
want to watch dude let's watch zack
snyder's zack snyder's sucker punch by
zack snyder girl black lightning
oh um
oh
chantal thuy
yes damn good pool john thanks
yeah i learned her name for me that's
right she temporarily followed us mm-hmm
and then she said
that three-month window expires she's
like i'm out they're not covering black
fun
keep it within the family
all right let's do a page
mark leach i am just discovering that
you're back at our patreon page mark
welcome it's good to have you back shout
out this white guy for this white guy
movie because you know what man
this is a boring movie but you you're
not boring at all no you're the real
goku you have a big heart and soul man
all the messages we used to exchange
with each other two paragraphs of those
messages are more exciting than 90
minutes of this movie i want everyone to
know that
it's all because of the insane words of
wisdom mark leach always has to offer
our way it's great to have you but i
want you to leech on to my heart
fill me with love
fill me up mark his words be my
buttercup margalitch
[Music]
me my buttercup
leech you and me
i beseech thee
touch i've shown you stuff so now if
you're starting
here dude um that's may i hope you
enjoyed multiverse and madness if not um
well hey it's better than this
good to have you back mark i love you
more than anyone in your actual
surroundings loves you mm-hmm i want you
to know that i'll betray you in a
heartbeat me i'm the only friend you got
out there
so watch your back punch your back man
you can't even trust me it's only him
only me man yeah i'm telling you i can't
trust those people now
[Music]